the Raptors took to an Oracle and
tonight could be the biggest night in
Toronto sports since Joe Carter took
Mitch Williams yard in the 1993 World
Series it is a big night in Toronto and
Jeff Van Gundy back here on the show
getting set to call another NBA Finals
game on ABC hari Jeff everything I'm
great can you put in perspective what
we're seeing from Kawhi Leonard because
obviously we're getting a lot a lot is
getting lost in the the Warriors are all
banged up shuffle what do you what do
you what have you personally witnessed
from Leonard and how you can relate to
what you've seen before in finals and or
playoffs history well it's just a great
great player I think a lot of people
have taken a lot of time to speculate
about his personality to speculate about
where he's going to play next season
about his load management or about how
he forced his way out of San Antonio all
those things sometimes obscure the
bigger point to me which is this guy's a
great great basketball player and his
ability to get to a spot on the floor
and elevate over people is not the same
as Durant but it's similar Durant does
it what size winner does it with size
length and strength but they're both
when they get into that mid-range area
or absolutely impossible to guard and
the last game you know just scored big
he's getting to the free-throw line and
also he's just not he didn't turn the
ball over so when you go on the road in
these type of games and you can keep
your turnovers low as a team and it
starts with your best player you got a
heck of a shot and you know conversely
Golden State I believe had 19 turnovers
it's hard to win that way in these
really really high-level games and it
seems that the Raptors have taken on his
persona certainly Jeff I don't know how
much you're on social media or Twitter
but a video of the team walking off the
court
after taking Game four
the Raptors walking back into their
locker room and it looked like they lost
by 20 it looked like that they didn't
have any sense of being on the precipice
of anything and it to me that would be
the most scary piece of video if I'm a
Warriors fan that they are just locked
in Jeff I'm wondering what you're seeing
well you're right about my lack of
social media presence I'm not a big guy
on that but I do think they have a very
workmanlike
game style and star so everything you
know to me fits together I think they
have a very experienced team that
understands that you know it takes four
and they've been part think about it now
in the Milwaukee series not only were
they down o2 but they were ready to go
down a three and pulled it out in
overtime and then won the next three to
advance and so they know how quickly
things can change from good to bad but
also from bad to good if you're Golden
State and so I think they have a very
mature approach I think they're
well-positioned obviously and right now
with the teams that both teams are
putting on the floor they're a far
superior team talent wise so what do you
expect to see with Durant tonight right
now obviously it's a large mystery and
there was word that he did in fact
practice significant time or no
significant time with the team what what
do you expect to see tonight Jeff well I
I don't expect him to play but if he is
able to play I think you have to didn't
judge you know is he healthy enough to
play effectively but if he's healthy the
time off while it was worrying me first
most he's such a huge talent upgrade
that he'll be a positive at both ends of
the floor I think people forget about
how good he is defensively now how he's
grown in that area and so I would
suspect if he's able to play normal
minutes
tonight you know +30
I would suspect he's going to score over
20 I mean as I think he said it like I'm
Kevin Durant and that's exactly what I
expect to see a guy who can take a month
off and get buckets so I guess the
question I have that well why do you
think he's not playing what give you
that indication or sense or belief
I just don't think from a health
standpoint it's progressed to where
either she feels or they feel that he's
able to go out there and compete I know
it's been a long-running speculation it
if you take it all the way back to when
he got injured in Houston people were
talking like I wonder if they'll be able
to play the next game and it made me
sense that they didn't really understand
what like a calf's Pole was I mean it's
a it's a debilitating injury it's not
something like a hand injury or even a
hamstring like it is hard to play with
that and and so from the start I didn't
think he would be back in the playoffs
but I think because of the speculation
day to day all he made taught practice
today it never left them it was the
constant source of questioning and I'm
not saying it has had any impact on
their play but it certainly has had been
a a thing that has never been put to
rest because the expectation for them to
play the next game has been there since
the Portland series Jeff Van Gundy here
on the Rich Eisen show what do you think
o is going through curves mind because
obviously he can't just wave a wand and
make that calf injury go away and he is
a former player and shooter knows
exactly exactly potentially what what
that would mean how does a coach handle
this Jeff I think you try to get your
group to lock in on what you have versus
what you don't have and I think he can
make a compelling point to his team
listen we're not playing well that's the
bottom line
we're not playing well we're giving up
pick-and-roll layups right where we're
not taking the
oh man we can correct that we can take
care of the ball better we can make our
free-throws like stuff that can be taken
care of without Durant much like gain to
here we can win a game and if we win a
game and I would say this then I promise
you we're gonna win Game six and we'll
be back here in Game seven that's what I
would try to paint the picture at would
you sit down Durant and just have a
conversation just a one-on-one look I'm
in the eye what's going on with your
calf I think probably I think the
communication between coach and player
it doesn't have to be as formal as
something like that as you have I'm sure
he said everyday communication them and
so I think you know when you've coached
this guy three years I think you have a
good handle on who he is and how you
best deal with him and obviously this
has been I'm sure stressful for Durant
too because he realizes their ability to
compete at the highest level despite
what some in the media we're trying to
paint at during you know the Portland
series that they may be better without
Durant I think Iran understand and the
Warriors understand that when you're
playing at the highest level you need
your best players not just there but
playing well and so I'm sure the stress
on Durant knowing that much of the fate
of this series depends on him and his
help I'm sure it's been hard for him
well I mean don't you think that the
four games of the NBA Finals have put
that supposition that you are hearing
about that a lot we're talking about in
that Blazers series that they're better
off without Durant or they're no worse
without Durant don't you think that's
put this to bed Jeff well I already
thought it was the bet I don't even
think it got a room in my house he's
gonna think about like you know the
thing is roots and I just shows you
perspective when Toronto played at a
higher percentage of winning a winning
percentage without Leonard this year in
the 22 games that he missed then he
played in so they put it better without
Leonard than with Leonard in the regular
season
was saying you know what I think we're
gonna be a little bit better without him
in the playoffs but for some reason when
the media either they don't know or they
go for the drama they paint these
pictures that like no one in basketball
would say oh yeah the way to get better
lose to rant did that work out for
Oklahoma City as it worked out so far
for Golden State no it doesn't work that
way
this guy is an elite talent who is so
improved as a passer and a handler and a
you know he's such a great shot creator
there's no guarding him in the
half-court
so you know gives you a shot where at
times where you need a guy and then get
ffensive LY he's able to compete against
multiple different positions so their
depth as we know has been compromised
over the years the depth of their talent
if you put up the roster from their
first championship season to now it is
absolutely night and day that drop-off
in overall depth but so what they win
with is star power but if one of the
stars is out it makes it difficult and
if another star is compromised in klay
Thompson even harder so these are real
issues that can't be overcome with talk
or you know thinking somehow you take an
elite talent out and you know like no
coach believes in that whole you know
next man up if the next man up was as
good as the guy up we pay in the same
amount it's true Jeff I just think that
in in the talk industry sports talk
industry of which your network is part I
sit behind this mic three hours a day so
I think about this all the time I just
think that so many folks in the Sports
Talk industry cannot get over the fact
that Durant left Oklahoma City for
Golden State and that that affects his
legacy forevermore and will always
affect it until he decides to do
something
else I don't believe that and I think
that's why everybody's reading into that
four-game sweep without Durant was
something that writ large means the
Warriors don't need him tell me that
that cry me that River July first I mean
that's insane that is just to me insane
Jeff right so I agree with you I think
to rants leaving Oklahoma City I see I
can understand people saying they didn't
like his decision and as fans they have
every reason or every right to say that
a I don't agree with that you know while
we acknowledge his right to do whatever
he wants in free agency I as Joe fan I
think I would have rather him stayed in
Oklahoma City okay
that's one thing but to then take that
and morph it into a team is actually
better without Durant that's just silly
and if you were watching the Portland
series closely yes they swept but it
covered up the fact that they got down
big in games two three and four and beat
a Portland team that was also beat up
with Newark itch being out and so the
Warriors as most teams do a lot of this
is who's the healthiest in sport and
they've had some breaks along the way in
this great run that they've had in the
playoffs what guides for other teams
missing now they're on the wrong end of
it and Toronto's benefiting from a
health advantage so I just think
sometimes it's simpler than we make it
and when you look out there and you
watch Kevin Durant play if you don't say
hey this guy is one of the great players
to have ever played this game then
you're you're you're being you're
overlooking his greatness for a
different narrative because you don't
like something about him right Jeff I
appreciate the call a great broadcast
I've really enjoyed it and just again
just to let everyone know behind the
scenes you're the one who spotted Van
Vleet stew thon the flu
right Jeff you were not gonna let Game
four continue without that being picked
up Friday night right well listen I I
love Fred vanvleet rich problem I went
to a practice of his at Wichita State
his senior year they had Ron Baker so I
know their coach Greg Marshall and he
wasn't overly athletic but I'll tell you
Greg Marshall is a special coach he was
you know like he's demanding and afraid
being sweet was like right in it so I
wasn't surprised keep hope in harm's way
and I wasn't surprised he was ready to
participate again that guy is not only a
great player
but he's also he's got Hall of Fame type
toughness no kidding cop dude yellow we
saw that I mean the blood and then that
tooth on the floor my gosh and it looked
like they were about to keep going like
no one saw hey Jeff thanks for the call
appreciate it have a great broadcast to
Game five and let's chat down the line
please all right always enjoy that's
Jeff Van Gundy calling Game five on ABC
tonight for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app